der herbst ist da das heißt es gibt
einiges zu tun damit wir mit unseren
gärten beruhigt in den tiefen kalten
winter starten können los geht's
jetzt gilt es den wetterbericht im auge
zu behalten weil es natürlich die ersten
fröste anstehen vielleicht hat es sogar
schon bei dem einen oder der anderen von
euch gefroren und dann geht es natürlich
die ganzen wärmeliebenden gemüse
abzuernten ich habe in den letzten
wochen ganz viel mit meinen tomaten hand
hier die letzten grünen tomaten gepflegt
die pflanzen rausgenommen die jetzt
sowieso von der braunfäule auch
irgendwann dahingerafft wurden die
süßkartoffeln geerntet die letzten
kartoffeln ausgegraben und alle pflanzen
abgeerntet die den forst nie einfach mal
so wegstecken ich kann euch gerne mal
eine liste einblenden mit den gemüsen
die ich an eurer stelle jetzt noch vor
den ersten frösten abernten würde ich
bei euch in die video beschreibung ein
link zu einem video wo ich euch zeige
wie man grüne tomaten nach reißen lässt
für diejenigen von euch die vielleicht
noch ein paar grüne tomaten an den
sträuchern hängen haben man kann so
nämlich bis weihnachten eigene frische
tomaten aus dem garten ist das total
genial dann steht wahrscheinlich bei
euch jetzt auch der letzte große ein
koch und fermentiert marathon an ich
ernte jetzt alle möglichen gemüse ab die
nächsten vorstellt sind und macht noch
mal richtig viel für den winter haltbar
damit wenn auch mit einer ganz prall
gefüllten vorratskammer die bis oben hin
mit schätzen gefüllt ist in den winter
starten können und bei uns brodelt
gerade ganz viele apfelmus auf dem herd
fermentieren noch das letzte sauerkraut
liegt ganz viel ein und das fühlt sich
total gut an nochmal einmal richtig ran
zu klotzen und dann aber auch genug
haltbar gemacht zu haben für den winter
denkt daran dass sie auf jeden fall noch
den knoblauch steckt und auch die winter
steckt zwiebeln wenn ihr winter zwiebeln
anbauen möchte weil beide einen großen
wachstumsvorsprung haben wenn ihr sie
jetzt noch vor dem winter steckt und das
geht jetzt auch noch wunderbar ich habe
jetzt auch noch nicht allen knoblauch
gepflanzt muss auch noch mal ran und
dann kennen die vor dem winter schon ein
bisschen aufgehen und kennen da nächstes
jahr gleich los wachsen sobald die
ersten warmen tage da sind wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie man knoblauch pflanzt
dann schaut gerne mal die video
beschreibung da packe ich euch nämlich
auch einen link zu den passenden video
rein genauso könnte jetzt auch noch
blumenzwiebeln stecken ich habe mir
wunderschöne blumen libyen besorgt
dieses jahr und wird schon ziemlich
scharf darauf die der nächstes jahr
blühen zu sehen der großteil meiner
bitte bleibt natürlich für die gemüse
serviert ist klar aber ich werde jedes
jahr ein bisschen mehr zufügen freundin
und alle blumenfreunde unter euch kennen
ja auch mitmachen und einfach noch ein
paar schöne blumenzwiebeln in die erde
bringen damit das schönste ist es
wahrscheinlich dass ganze tolle laupen
dass ich gerade so wunderschön färbt und
runter fällt und dann auf gerecht werden
will und das herbstlaub ist auch
wunderbar geeignet um die ganzen
wintergemüse die im beet stehen bleiben
damit ganz dick zu mulchen unschön
einzupacken weil das die richtig schön
isoliert so dass ihr zum beispiel auch
möhren noch bei leichten kosten ernten
könnt wenn ihr die im beet stehen lassen
wollte und deswegen kann ich meine
wintergemüse jetzt in der schönen dick
gemütliche laubschicht 1 denkt auch
daran dass es überhaupt nicht schlimm
ist wenn in einer ecke im garten mal so
ein laubhaufen liegen bleibt weil das
ein super gemütliches winterquartier für
igel ist gerne auch einfach alle
blütenstände und so weiter stehen das in
einer insekten drin überwintern können
und nahrung finden und den garten gar
nicht so picobello aufräumen wie man das
vielleicht gern machen würde
vielleicht auch ganz nett wenn man mal
faul sein darf aber ich entferne solche
sachen zb erst wieder richtung frühling
wenn die gischt und wieder aus dem
winterschlaf aufgewacht sind und die
insekten auch anderweitig wieder
unterschlupf von nahrung finden wenn ihr
den freeway kasten habe die man zum
beispiel auf einen hoch bild drauf
montieren kann dann holt ihn wo ich
jetzt schon mal raus es war oft einfach
fürs frühjahr gedacht und da schnell die
ersten sachen drin pflanzen zu können
aber darunter könnt ihr auch gemüse wie
rote beete und spinat und so weiter noch
ein bisschen besser schützen wir könnten
auch salat im winter anbauen das ist
eine super sache die nicht nur im
frühling zu nutzen sondern jetzt auch im
winter meiner ist schon fest montiert
man kann ja im winter super wie lee
gemüse noch im bett stehen lassen aber
ein paar sind davon ein bisschen
empfindlicher als andere wie zb der
kohlrabi den lasse ich gerne bis
weihnachten oder länger im beet stehen
aber in ganz kalten nächten freute sich
wenn man ihn mit einem vlies abdeckt mit
einem gärtner vlies und dann kann man
auch kleine mini tunnels aufbauen wo man
denn das gärtner fließt rüber spannend
oder gewächshaus wo ihr darüber spannt
um das noch zusätzlich zu isolieren also
daran denken wir einfach mal zu gucken
wie vor zeit sind denn die gemüse die
noch im winter stehen bleiben sollen und
dann schauen dass man die richtig
schützt gerade auch gemüse wie in die
viren freuen sich wenn sie im winter ein
dach über dem kopf haben weil es oft ein
bisschen zu feucht ist im winter für die
und die dann schnell wegfallen können
wenn man dann eine folie darüber spannt
oder die eben in einem früh mit kasten
anbaut dann hat man sehr viel bessere
chancen die dann auch über den winter zu
kriegen wegen schickeria angebaut habt
dann könnt ihr den jetzt ausgraben und
die wurzeln rausholen ich hab das noch
gar nicht gemacht ich muss auf jeden
fall auch dringend noch ran und den
chicorée in den keller bringen dann
könnt ihr die wurzeln im keller in einem
blumentopf pflanzen einfach mit
blumenerde befüllt und dann in eimer
darüber stülpen damit die schön dunkel
sind und da treiben dann die theorie
köpfen raus nicht alle wurzeln auf
einmal pflanzen wer sonst hat man allen
theorie auf einmal man kann die auch
gestaffelt treiben dafür schlage ich die
wurzeln immer einzeln in zeitungspapier
ein und lagere die in der ungekühlten
garage ungekühlt
frostfreien garage oder auch im
gewächshaus wenn ich nicht zu kalt ist
lagern die sich auch eine weile so dass
man nach und nach dann immer den
chicorée holen und einpflanzen kann und
dann treiben da die köpfchen aus ist
eine super sache und winter auch ein
bisschen weiter gärtnern zu können
außerdem ist der herbst die beste zeit
und beerensträucher und obstbäume zu
pflanzen ich weiß nicht ob ich das hier
schon mal erzählt habe aber in meinen
kursen empfehle ich immer allen dass sie
zuallererst die obstbäume und
beerensträucher pflanzen wenn sie einen
neuen garten planen weil das die
pflanzen sind die am längsten brauchen
bis man zum ersten mal ernten kann da
können schon mal fünf jahre ins land
gehen bevor man seine ersten eigenen
äpfel hat und deswegen immer dran denken
so früh wie möglich einen schönen
obstgarten anzupflanzen damit man dann
auch irgendwann was davon hat und da
gebe ich total gerne eine handvoll
gerstenkörner mit ins pflanzloch fragt
mich nicht wie wissenschaft dahinter ist
aber es funktioniert meiner erfahrung
nach richtig gut die fahrer und autos
vorbei ich hoffe das stört euch nicht zu
viel mir gerade voll im
feierabendverkehr aber jedenfalls
erwachten handball gerstenkörner mit ins
pflanzloch geben und dann im stimuliert
ist das wurzelwachstum so dass die
pflanzen
anwachsen wo wir gerade bei apfelbäumen
sind wenn ihr jetzt eure apfelbäume
abgeerntet habt und die kirchen ja
sowieso dann schaut mal ob in den bäumen
noch so genannte frucht mumien hängen
also alte verfaulte früchte und wenn
irgendwie dran kommt und das einrichten
könnt dann versucht die myphone den beim
runter zu pflücken auch von
beerensträuchern weil sich da gerne
schädlinge drin einnisten und
krankheiten drin überwintern können so
dass ein baum der nächstes jahr sofort
wieder befallen wird und so könnt ihr
den baum offenen natürliche und schon
der art und weise gesund erhalten wenn
jetzt viele gemüse auch das beet räumen
oder man ja auch viel laub hat im garten
und super für organisches material
anfällt dann ist das auch eine super
zeit um den neuen komposthaufen
anzusetzen da immer darauf achten dass
man ein gutes verhältnis aus braun und
grün materialien zusammen nicht so dass
der schnell umgesetzt werden kann wenn
ihr schon den bestehenden kompost ab
dann könnt ihr den jetzt noch mal vom
münchner umsätzen einfach alles was eben
das nach außen schichten als was außen
ist nach innen schichten und dann ist es
auch ganz klug den kompost über den
winter abzudecken dass da nicht so viel
regen platscht nicht so viele nährstoffe
ausgewaschen werden wusstet ihr dass man
jetzt auch noch kartoffeln pflanzen kann
die dann im wird überwintern und im
frühling ganz schnell anfangen zu
wachsen so dass man hoffentlich eine
größere ernte hat nächstes jahr und
früher ernten kann das hat bei mir
richtig gut funktioniert ich habe das
jetzt letztes jahr zum ersten mal
ausprobiert aber dieses jahr werden auf
jeden fall wieder kartoffeln im herbst
oder winter gepflanzt also schaut gerne
meiner trieben vorbei wenn euch
interessiert die das genau funktioniert
ansonsten geht raus nach die welt ein
bisschen grüner und wir sehen uns
nächsten samstag mit einem wie ich bin
der wunderschöner in video vista